hi I'm Erik Bosse and Star Wars the last
Jedi is the most polarizing film of the
year with one of the biggest gaps
between critics ratings and audience
scores for a major film ever what the
hell is going on here
why are some people so annoyed with it
saying it ruined what made the original
trilogy and of course awakens so good
why are others fanboy crush scenes so
hard over it calling it the best Star
Wars film ever made seriously that's
maybe but most importantly what is the
deeper agenda of this film that explains
why it makes some of these bolder
narrative decisions I'm gonna explore
all those questions pointed out some
subtle details in the last Jedi that you
might miss and in the process I'm
probably gonna say something you
disagree with it but I'll wager that
you'll want to watch the movie again and
no I'm not paid by Lucasfilm to make
these supportive videos um Oh Kathleen
Eric is spelled with a k we're gonna
need to reprint this check it's a napkin
napkin and real quick this video was
sponsored by movement watches and
sunglasses check out the description
below for more info or a stick around at
the end for details on a special offer
boilers ed if you have not seen the last
Jedi okay let's start with some of the
reasons people are really frustrated
with this movie from what I can tell
their complaints fall into four
categories first some people are simply
saying the film it's too long and it's
not that 2 hours and 30 minutes it's too
long for a movie it's that they feel
this movie feels a lot longer to be fair
the main story does involve a resistance
fleet crawling through space just out of
range of the first order as they bleed
ships one by one
meanwhile the secondary story follows
Luke and Leia bickering back and forth
on aceh 2 to train or not to train just
make up your mind but the C story of
this film is what critics are really
grumbling about the second major gripe
finn and roses canto bytes subplot many
viewers felt this section of the movie
was unnecessary reliant on too many cgi
characters in an underdeveloped wild
card character DJ who seems really
inconsequential to the overall story
the third complaint is the film's sense
of humor some viewers are suggesting to
the film it's too jokey too indulgent on
meta references and modern style jokes
that they argue weren't really true to
the characters for example people are
pointing to Luke sarcastically brushing
off his shoulder after Kyle Lohse
barrage and they say that this is a very
sassy move that a Jedi master would not
do
maybe qui-gon was pretty sassy with that
battle droid on that
though ambassador to the Supreme
Chancellor I'm taking these people to
Coruscant where are you taking that do
Gerson really the film's overall
treatment of Luke is the fourth big
thing that bothers some viewers they
argue that Luke Skywalker comes off as
too weak in that Luke as we know from
the original trilogy would never pull a
lightsaber on a kid even for a second
even Mark Hamill admitted that he
initially completely disagreed with how
Rian Johnson was changing the character
some people are going as far to accuse
Rian Johnson of completely undercutting
all of the promise fans had after the
force awakens for Ray's origin and Snoke
is a villain in the Knights of Ren
ignoring some of those elements or
oversimplifying them by properly cutting
off the mystery ensure there was some
other gripes people had like the
unceremonious death of Captain phasma
and some people just really hate poor
words let's move on to some of the
reasons people said they loved the movie
and general there seem to be three big
strengths that the last Jedi fans are
unanimous about first how central Luke
and Leia are to this story Mark Hamill
and Carrie Fisher are driving forces in
this movie and we get to see the
characters as they've aged and the weary
embattled souls while getting these
sweet reminders of their past adventures
second the action when this movie brings
it totally delivers spans are
considering the opening Battle of Dakar
in the closing battle of crate among the
best battle scenes in all the Star Wars
films and they're putting the visual
spectacle of the destruction of the
supremacy up there with the destruction
of the Death Star as unforgettable film
images third everyone seems happy with
how central Poe Dameron is to the story
in The Force awakens Poe remains off
screen most of the film but here this
zeroes arc is very well defined and
interesting now whichever side you fall
on I actually think there's truth to
both sides
I agree the film might bite off more
than it can chew with its story
especially with the cancer bite subplot
and not all the jokes land but I also
totally agree with the reasons people
love it and then some but here's what I
believe is a true intent of this movie
which might explain why it's getting
such passionate reactions from viewers
the purpose of the last Jedi as I see it
is to force fans to let go and move on
from their worship of the past legends
of the franchise from the very beginning
of the film the last shed I makes it
clear that it does not idolize the
characters and events from the past
Luke's first move of the film is to
Chuck his long-lost sacred lightsaber
off a cliff and then bark at us to
essentially get off his lawn meanwhile
Leia snaps at Poe there are things you
cannot saw
by jumping into an x-wing and blowing
something up she's hinting that Poe
didn't totally learn anything from
blowing up Starkiller base in the force
awakens but she's also implying Luke
didn't really learn anything by blowing
up the Death Star over and over
throughout this film ryan johnson
subverts our expectations forcing us to
rethink our past assumptions the Jedi
are the good guys they're just one-half
of an equation that's just as arrogant
as the other half and it's time for
their order to burn to Ray's parents are
the defining mystery of the new trilogy
not quite she's not a Skywalker she's a
nobody as the opening of the force
awakens
indicated she was and her actions prove
her wealth not her bloodline Supreme
Leader Snoke is a man behind the curtain
all right he's just another proud master
with a blind spot for is more powerful
apprentice characters in this movie join
us on this learning curve as one by one
they have to let go of something they
once held dear as kylo said let the past
die kill it if you have to ray let's go
of her goal to find out the truth of her
parents
kylo let's go of his emulation of Darth
Vader and his faithfulness to his master
Poe let's go of his need to score small
victories realizing retreat is sometimes
a better option Leia lets go of her
fleet pretty much her entire resistance
forces the movie makes it painful to
watch to death by a thousand cuts Luke
lets go of his solitude in his
retirement even a smaller character like
Rose lets go of her precious pendant the
remaining connection to her deceased
sister all of these separations are on
the surface failures for these
characters but they're also the source
of their triumphs because they show
those characters learning from those
defeats in finding inner balance with
this shift as Yoda says explicitly in
this movie the greatest teacher failure
is so it went away the last Jedi as a
film has to be kind of a downer to
achieve this evolution for its
characters has to make these people
complicated and messy
it has to dimensionalize them beyond the
simple archetypes they were in the
original trilogy and in a way in the
force awakens if you think about it the
last Jedi pulls a lot of the same moves
the Empire Strikes Back did they both
made their worlds darker they both
reverse the feel-good charm of their
predecessors and they both had super
exciting opening and closing acts but
kind of more slowly paced middle
sections I would argue that the main
reason general audiences were so excited
about the Empire Strikes Back was really
its
cliffhanger but out it their reaction
might have been similar to those
grumbling over the last Jedi today in
fact initial reviews for The Empire
Strikes Back were kind of mixed and it
wasn't until decades later that a lot of
people started to consider it the best
of the Star Wars franchise now all that
said I think this letting go fail your
theme being so well developed in the
last Jedi is also the reason this canto
byte subplot stands out so much it's not
that it's bad it's just that it has a
different agenda Ben Rose and DJ
storyline is driven by commentary on war
profiteering it's actually politically
charged when you look at it Johnson
cleverly uses a casino setting in the
father horse races to analogize the way
the galaxy's arms dealers gamble with
the sides of the war DJ leaves Finn with
this profoundly cynical message that the
Wars of Star Wars never end they're all
a machine to make money and you know
what I really dig all of that that's a
really cool well-thought-out
storytelling there the problem is it's
just not that be magically connected
with the rest of the last Jedi like if
this were part of a three-part HBO
miniseries depicting these events I'd be
down for it honestly after watching the
last Jedi like me you might have felt
that you just binge dassey's another
show and this is part of the reason why
I get why Rian Johnson wanted to include
can't abide he wanted to show a side of
the galaxy that's never been seen before
in a Star Wars film and he wanted to
expand his approach to deepen the good
versus evil battle into a more morally
complex one into a new front of this war
where he could make some sharper
political observations unfortunately he
just did such a good job with the core
of the rest of this movie just makes
this subplot feel like thirty minutes
maybe the movie doesn't need but looking
at the last Jedi as a whole by forcing
these characters down paths we could
never predict Brian Johnson forced us to
see the men and women behind the legends
and that true story is so much more
interesting because otherwise all you're
left with is mythology the
sensationalized toy story that the kids
at the end of the last Jedi tell each
other before they go to bed the closing
shot suggests that the true power of
Star Wars is its ability to inspire us
to look upward and dreamless something
even greater than the tales we've been
told to as Yoda put it grow beyond what
our masters our love it or hate it the
last Jedi's showed Rian Johnson to be a
student who took that challenged heart
now a quick thanks to movement for
sponsoring this video
movement offers super stylish watches
and sunglasses that I wear
all the time they have this sleek
minimalist design that I'm a big fan of
because uh many of you have pointed out
I tend to wear this one beaver shirt all
the time but you know what you'd be
surprised how well a classy movement
watch or sunglasses just draws the
attention away baby
the watches start at 95 bucks and the
glasses at 70 bucks you could even get
him polarized which I need because my
eyes are weak get $15 off today plus
free shipping and free returns just go
to MVM t.com slash new rockstars and use
the code new rockstars when checking out
or you can click on the link in the
description below joined the movement
guys thank you for watching this video
be sure to check out my full in-depth
breakdown on the last Jedi as well as my
explanation of kylos decision to kill
Snoke comment down below and tweet me
directly at da boss we're probably new
rockstars on twitter at new rockstars
for updates on our video like this video
and subscribe the new rock stars for
deep dives and all the stuff you love
all the Star Wars stuff but also Marvel
Game of Thrones anything really and if
you really like us you can contribute to
us on patreon big thanks to all of our
donors especially Alan Fleming thanks
for watching guys bye